Welcome back to Drew's News.
We're celebrating our own Deborah Norville Day.
Oh, wow! Thank you!
With the incredible
Deborah Norville!
(audience cheering)
And I love this,
you know how there are so many fun things to celebrate,
and holidays now that we-
Mm-hmm.
Yeah.
Okay, so guess what?
This is every day's a holiday!
Hey!
Yes!
(audience cheering)
This is a really good holiday!
Oh, mercy.
This is a really
good holiday, you're absolutely right.
What holiday is it Deborah?
It is National Pizza Day,
Yeah.
And maybe you could tell from the table here.
My favorite day.
Oh, Drew, you know pizza is-
Okay, I'm gonna
take this off, I feel so silly.
I wouldn't even wear a veil when I got married.
Really?
So, yeah.
I look just ridiculous.
I was thinking that
you do look really sexy in it, though.
I'm telling you.
Well, Ross, I wanna know, is it scientifically true
that pizza is proven to make us happy?
Is this a fact?
I am going to say yes, it is a fact,
and it actually does come from a scientific study.
Slice says the smell of pizza actually does make us happy.
I don't need a scientist to tell me that, by the way.
Even just thinking about pizza,
releases something called dopamine in you.
Okay.
Which makes you happy.
And when you bite into that slice,
carbs will actually give you a boost of serotonin.
So scientists said I could eat pizza today.
Thank you very much.
(crowd cheering)
Why do I think a pizza person did that study?
I don't care
who did that study.
I totally support it,
by the way.
I'm buying all those facts.
All right. Well, let's dig in.
We've got an eight-foot mama
from Biga Bite, right here,
Wow!
in New York City.
Yum. I want it.
This is such a thing of beauty.
I can't thank them enough for providing us with this pizza.
Now, you are a Chicago-
I am and I recognized it before
the food person even confirmed.
This is a Chicago deep dish pizza
from Lou Malnati's.
Oh!
I'm gonna show you right here.
The best.
I'll be taking a piece.
We were literally,
I can attest, I was standing here.
It slid in, and Deborah goes "Lou Malnati's".
Yeah.
Wow.
You guys look, can you see this cheese
on this one that I'm pulling off?
And it's warm. It's warm.
Hi!
You're gonna be in my tummy. Hi.
And this is from Buddy's in Detroit.
This is called a Detroit-style pizza.
They do it square in Detroit.
I wanna try that.
I love Detroit.
And look at this, the coolest cutter.
Cute.
How cute is that?
And show yours. Yours is even cuter.
Is this a cutter?
This is a cutter.
Look at that guys.
Oh, look!
It's a bicycle.
I didn't even see that.
So you can cut your pieces with a bicycle.
Cute. You'll be little.
So, you can just
drive it across there.
Yeah.
(audience chuckling)
And back it up over that-a-way.
Oh, this is really good.
This is a wheel-y
great idea.
Whoa, bada bing! Okay.
Am I supposed to be doing anything?
Because all I'm doing,
You lost me.
is putting my face in here.
I'm like, "Oh gosh, I am at work".
But I literally, I had that moment where I was like-
Yum.
Well, the great thing
about pizza is you can order it and be happy.
You can make at home and be happy.
(audience cheering)
Yum!
And that's what happy looks like.
Mm. So I have a question for you.
Where do you lie on Hawaiian pizza?
Like the pineapple?
I would never.
(Ross laughing)
I just-
I'm sorry.
No offense to the lovely people of Hawaii,
but I don't think you put a pineapple on a pizza.
It's just a personal thing.
See, I'm okay with it.
Really?
Are you eating it?
No, you're not.
I wasn't, but I will now,
Deborah, just to make a point.
(audience cheering)
Oh my God.
I am shockingly,
you know how we are so different at times, Ross,
I am on the pineapple express.
(Ross chuckling)
Really?
Uh-huh.
Do you know what?
Because you're so encouraging, Drew.
There she goes.
We're gonna do a little taste test.
Okay.
Oh, you're gonna try it!
You're gonna do it!
Confront my fears.
(Ross laughing)
And here we go.
(audience chuckling)
Meh.
Okay.
(audience laughing)
(audience applauding)
But, you tried.
I tried.
Ladies and gentlemen,
Thank you!
Aw, Deborah.
Deborah Norville.
Catch her every weekday on Inside Edition,
(audience cheering)
(Ross clapping)
or on your YouTube channel
Or YouTube, yeah.
with the 18 billion views.
Yay, YouTube.
We'll be right back.
Thank you, so much.
(bright music)